but how does a writer protect themselves
from getting taken advantage of
even though they have that they they
really want that
thing to pay off for them again i think
i think the most important thing a
writer can do
is obviously you have to copyright your
material and that includes the
treatments
it includes the script and i think you
have to take
you have to take notes of where projects
go
you know i look back at some of the
projects i had ripped off and if i had
just taken better notes
just documented who what when where and
why
i could have stopped them from being
taken or at least gotten to partake in
its success or failure
from a producer or creator standpoint
and i just think it's too easy to
you know be people when we're coming up
we want
so bad to have our work accepted we want
to make it so bad whether we're an actor
or a writer
the problem is if you're an actor and
you want to make it you can audition you
can go out and meet people and do your
thing but
your only calling card as a writer is to
write and unfortunately
everything starts with the script you
don't have an actor attached
you don't have a producer a director a
set financing until
what's the script it's all about the
script so you're kind of kicking off the
whole project
and the most valuable thing that
somebody can take
is a script it's the only thing they can
take they can't take an actor they can't
take a director
they can't steal a craft service person
they're going to steal the script
so you have to really think that you're
really the the lifeblood of a project
you are the inception
of the project and what you have is gold
to some people
so you have to protect it you have to
you have to take as much time as you've
taken
to write your script you have to think i
have to copyright it i have to copyright
every bit of
intellectual property that surrounds it
whether it's your beat sheets your
breakdown your
you know your boards whatever it is you
just you got to protect everything
and then you have to really really be
clear on who you've given it to
why you're giving it to me and i also be
careful who you're giving it to you know
hungry writers i can't tell you how
often well this this producer reached
out to me
on uh you know facebook and uh you know
they i sent them three of my scripts i
never heard from them again it's like
well okay did you look up who the
producer was well you know he
he had this ac credit on a film two
years ago and
you know look if if a real producer
wants to work with you they're not going
to
find you on facebook usually now i
understand it is a way to find people
but how did they find you on facebook
did they read something else you wrote
and
facebook was the only way to find you or
were they just trolling
for people in the writing forums and the
writing you know
uh what are they called the writing
forms
of facebook and that's where a lot of
these people get taken advantage of it's
really easy
all you have to do is dm one writer
who's writing something on the board
that you think is intelligent
gullible vulnerable and hungry enough
and just say hey
uh here's who i am i'm interested in
what you got i'd love to read your work
and
nine times out of nine they're probably
gonna send it you know screen cap those
conversations get this guy's name
look them up start a file on everybody
you send stuff to you should have a file
on every project
and a file on everybody who sees
whatever project you have
and that's a big way to protect yourself
a dossier
is that what that is i i've heard new
words that's what the government does
what is there there's the dossier and
then there's the
uh what's the other one oped i've heard
these new words since
the last four years i never knew before
and in the reverse
how can someone who's been asked to read
their script
vet a producer so seeing just like
one credit on imdb with no picture
no contact info very little online
presence is that someone who
you should really be sending your work
to i i always think it's important for
people to vet on the other side is
is you know we've talked about before
the easiest thing to do
if you're a person who has a business
card that says you're a producer but you
haven't physically produced
the easiest thing to do is go to
something like facebook and find a
writer's form
and find people that are you know all
you have to do is join it's free to join
and you get to see the trends and habits
and some of the idiosyncrasies of the
people that are on that site
and you start realizing their
vulnerabilities their hopes their fears
their concerns and where
they are careless i find it
amazing that people will actually say
here's my latest script
and throw it on a facebook forum and you
go
oh my god eric i'll say hey i just did
these 10 pages last night with love
feedback
okay um you know i think that's careless
but you know producers are predatory
uh by nature and sorry but they are that
you have something they want
so i think uh you need to protect your
work i think you need to
think twice before you just shotgun your
material out i think you need to look up
people
i still there's a lot of writers that i
respect that i know and i still try to
collaborate with that'll say oh i heard
from a producer
i sent this guy my work he reached out
to me and i'm looking i'm gonna go have
you
even oh no i know he doesn't have an
imdb presence or he doesn't even have
but he's you know and it's like not that
imdb is the
end all be all but good lord if somebody
has got
a history in the business of being
legitimate that's certainly one way to
better them
and i just it's mind-boggling how
how often people don't uh take the time
they don't want to hear the truth so
they just
they just shotgun it hoping that this
could be the one and i think they have
to be very careful hence you know
getting your
your projects ripped off several times
over your career because you're not
you know careful and i gave my projects
to
people that were real and legit but
i didn't protect myself and they know
when you don't
so even if someone's vetted doesn't
necessarily mean that you're safe
just because somebody's vetted doesn't
mean that you're safe i mean you know
um easiest thing to do is to
get a script that's not copy written
then have the power to make something
and get it from somebody who has no
cloud or juice or
voice or word in the industry
and if that's the case then what
what do they have to stand on if they're
not protected you know
so what if someone says well then maybe
i just shouldn't trust anybody
and why even then why even bother doing
this well you shouldn't you shouldn't
trust don't trust
anybody what you should do is protect
your work as we talked about before with
the you know
united states copyright office don't
waste your time with the wga
do it with the usco it's the same
process kind of
costs a little bit more but it's it
shows people that are in the know that
you're serious
um it shows that you know how to protect
your work and take copious notes
and you should have a file on each
project and you should have a file on
everybody that you send it to
that should be part of it and those
correspondences and if it's a phone call
take notes i talked to
shane stanley today it's october 1st
2020.
he said he wanted me to send a synopsis
emailed shane stanley at this email
address the synopsis for this story
waiting for a call back or a phone you
know an email and then when i email her
phone back
print it out put it in the file and that
way if i go off and make that movie
i've gotta it's now the burden of proof
is on me that i didn't rip them off
it's always on the rider to prove that i
that i ripped you off but now all of a
sudden
if you do your due diligence it's now on
me to show that
i have to now provide all the stuff that
i did to develop the material
and that's harder to do do you do this
like in excel
or award pages what i usually do
is i have a backup email address like if
i have my company account whatever it is
com i have a yahoo account that i don't
access or give out to anybody
all it is is my overages it's every time
i email a project to somebody i bcc it
and then that way i have it safe and
then when that person replies i have a
folder on my main
of each project so every time i get a
hit so i'm getting i got the send out
sent somewhere else
and then i've got the reply and a whole
different other email mass so that way
god forbid one crashes one goes blank or
gets hacked i at least have half the
conversation somewhere
that's how i do it that's great
you